wir treffen eines der bekanntesten
fernsehgesichtern chinas münchen spricht
fünf sprachen
sie arbeitet für den staatssender cctv
dessen aufgabe chinas ziele an die welt
zu verkaufen es wird ein gespräch über
journalismus propaganda und chinas rolle
im ukraine konflikt
wir sind auf englisch um einem
internationalen publikum zu erklären was
in china passiert welche pläne das land
innenpolitisch und außenpolitisch hat
wohin hat ihre eigene sendung sie
interviewt mächtige chinesische
politiker sie erklärt den handelskrieg
mit den usa die wirtschaftslage in china
und zurzeit vor allem den ukraine
konflikt und die beziehung peking zu
moskau als ein sprachrohr der partei
sieht sie sich nicht
gibt es für sie einen unterschied
zwischen chinesischem journalismus und
amerikanische oder deutsche
es sollte keinen geben wir alle haben
den job professionell zu sein wir
versuchen wahrheitsgemäß zu berichten so
fair und so ausgewogen wie es eben geht
in china definiert aber eher was wahr
ist und was nicht präsident sie hat die
aufgabe des journalisten klar bestimmt
und beschrieben sie haben den willen der
partei zu dienen münchen weiß dass sie
den präsidenten folgen muss auf
nachfragen räumte sie das ein
ich würde sagen dass die partei den
willen des volkes repräsentiert wenn ich
für das fernsehen arbeite dann arbeite
ich nicht gegen den willen des volkes
wir sehen in china die aufgabe der
medien anders als im westen sie glauben
aufgabe der medien sei die parteien zu
kritisieren nicht so bei uns unsere
aufgabe ist es den fortschritt der
gesellschaft zu unterstützen
wer in china als journalist war zu
widersprechen muss mit bitteren
konsequenzen rechnen das erlebte jimmy
lee der verleger von apple daily
2020 ließen ihn die peking treuen
gefolgsleute in hongkong haften jetzt
sitzt er im gefängnis seine zeitung
hatte immer wieder kritik an der
zerschlagung der freiheitsbewegung geübt
[Musik]
es ist sehr gefährlich in ihrem land als
journalist die regierung zu kritisieren
das ist wohl der große unterschied zu
unserer kultur
naja wer regeln die dinge eben anders
wenn sie gegen das chinesische gesetz
verstoßen dann glaube ich drohen ihnen
solche konsequenzen jeder muss das
gesetz des landes repräsentieren
aber wenn das gesetz sie zum terroristen
stempelt weil sie ihre meinung sagen
das habe ich nicht gesagt aber sie
müssen sich an das gesetz halten sie
müssen eben die traditionen und kultur
des landes respektieren
präsident ski hat seinen journalisten
befohlen der welt china sichtweise zu
erzählen das ist auch ein grund warum
der sender sixx etienne 2016 ins leben
gerufen wurde gerade jetzt wichtig denn
das enge verhältnis zwischen ski und
putin im ukraine kommt isoliert china
weltweit deshalb will wir ihn den
eindruck korrigieren dass china keine
probleme mit dem verhalten putins hat
es gibt auch eine menge chinesen die
putin nicht unterstützen das
meinungsbild ist eben nicht einseitig
absolut nicht viele haben heftige
debatten was jetzt geschehen muss
hinweis dass china für den westen neben
russland auf der anklagebank sitzt ihr
job ist es chinas image davon zu
befreien
wir können doch nicht behaupten china
hilft menschen umzubringen glauben sie
dass dann gibt es keine
gesprächsgrundlage
chinesen sind keine blutrünstigen
monster aber kein china denn wirklich
allein eine lösung finden wenn du bist
leopin wird morgen wieder auf sendung
gehen und chinas position im auftrag der
partei verkünden oder wie sie sagen
würde berichten